MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK:
All right.
I think we're going
to get started.
My name is Michael
Weiss-Malik.
I'm an Engineering Director
on Google Maps.
ANDREW LOOKINGBILL: My name's
Andrew Lookingbill.
I'm one of the Founding
Engineers on
Project Ground Truth.
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK: And we're
here to talk about Ground
Truth, accurate maps by
algorithms and elbow grease.
So first off, I'm a big fan of
data, Google is a big fan of
data, and we like to
visualize data.
So this is data on
the presentation.
This is the content of
We are intending to spend a
little bit of time on what
Ground Truth is, a little bit
of time on why Ground Truth
is, a bunch of time on how we
actually do Ground Truth, and
that's really the meat of the
presentation, how is it that
we make maps?
And finally, we'll wrap up with
a little bit of where we
have done Ground Truth so far.
So first, let's focus
on the what.
So what is Ground Truth?
This is a little wordy, but it
says it exactly right, a
project to create accurate and
comprehensive map data by
conflating multiple inputs via
algorithms and elbow grease.
And that's really wordy, but we
are going to break it down.
And the first thing is,
what is map data?
What are we actually talking
about when we talk about a
project to make good map data?
Well, for purposes of this talk,
we're going to define
map data as the vectors
on the map.
This is basically everything
you see on Google Maps that
isn't an image.
It's the roads, it's the postal
codes, it's stuff that
you don't see like speed limits,
city boundaries,
everything that makes Directions
work, Search work,
all of that data.
That's the data that we're
talking about creating.
So, having answered, what is map
data, there's actually a
bigger question-- what
is Google Maps?
Because the reason for Ground
Truth has to do with a whole
ecosystem of considerations.
So to answer that, we're going
to go on a slight segue.
Let's pretend that map data is
stored as movie film, just to
make a really simple
analogy, OK?
If you define it that way,
basically the way that Google
Maps has traditionally displayed
map data, is we've
had a data provider who went and
took measurements of the
world using--
here, through the analogy-- a
movie camera, and created that
film that they then tossed
over a line to us.
So there's the data provider
on one side and
Google on the other.
So what do we do
with the film?
We project it onto a screen.
In this case, it's a
drive-through screen, or your
laptop screen, or whatever,
but this is
the traditional ecosystem.
A data provider sits on
one side of the line.
They collect the data, they
toss it over to us, and we
take care of distributing
it to users.
Another way to look at this is
actually similar to a movie
rental store.
So basically, we have
to go and pick out
what titles are available.
And the arrangement suffered
from the same problems that
old VHS rental stores
suffered from.
The selection was limited.
The movie studios weren't
necessarily making the movie
that you wanted to make.
You had to pick from what
it was that they
were interested in.
And of course, the movie studio
didn't like it very
much if you edited the movie
before you returned it back.
So all these considerations,
this gets us back to, What is
Ground Truth?
Ground Truth is a completely
different ecosystem for
producing movies.
Basically, instead of this
rental model and this model
where there's a data provider
on one side of the line and
we're on the other,
we've now become a
movie production studio.
We are making our own maps,
hence the graphic at the
beginning of the presentation.
So that covers the what
of Ground Truth.
We're making maps.
We're making Google Maps,
Google Map data.
Why?
Why would we want to do this?
So this is motivated, actually,
by a couple of
considerations, not just the
inconvenience of the rental
model but actually all the data
that we had lying around.
This is some really cool high
resolution aerial imagery of
some backyards.
And I'm from Phoenix, so I
immediately recognize in this,
at the top of there is a tiny
little hose in a pool.
That's actually an automatic
pool cleaner hose.
It's literally the
size of my wrist.
We can spot this stuff
from the air now.
And that's nice, and that's good
eye candy, but what it
really means is that when we
look at roads, we can spot the
roads from imagery and
accurately map them.
We can accurately map
where you can turn,
where you can't turn.
You can literally
trace out a map.
And so a lot of the impetus for
this came from the fact
that Google had so much data
inside that we thought we
could leverage to make
good map data.
And of course, we have
Street View as well.
From Street View, we get a
tremendous amount of mapping
information.
We can see one-way streets, we
can see bicycle lanes, types
of roadways.
You can confirm street names,
you can confirm address
numbers, you can even extract
business logos.
And as we'll get to a little
later, we can do a lot of this
autonomously.
We can actually automatically
recognize numbers in Street
View imagery and run some
algorithms on them, and out
the other end pop millions of
addresses that we've actually
created in Google Maps, purely
from Street View imagery and
computer vision algorithms.
So it's not just enough
to have the data.
Why do we actually want to go
through all of this effort?
And it basically amounts to,
it benefits our users.
And there's a couple different
benefits that it offers.
The first is that through this
process, we wind up working
directly with authoritative
data providers.
In the movie analogy, we're
dictating the actors.
We're not going through
a studio.
So we get to pick if we want to
talk to a postal service or
a national park service, we work
directly with them and
get the best data
that can be had.
We also get to match our
investment to our user needs.
Google is a very
global company.
We have users in a lot of
different countries.
Map data providers may or may
not be investing in the same
places that we really want to
invest, so this lets us match
up to our users much,
much better.
And then lastly, speed,
speed, speed.
This is a big theme
of Ground Truth.
We do things quickly, and it
enables Google to do a lot of
things quickly.
We want to be able to publish
updates to the map, we want to
be able to accept updates to the
map, and the only way to
really do that on a tight cycle
is if you own the entire
map production.
Because previously, if you had
to report a problem with, say,
the map data in the US, you'd
have to go to one of our data
providers, wait six to 18 months
and hope that they
actually fix it, and then they'd
have to send the data
to us and then we'd have
to publish it.
Now, since we own the data, we
own the whole ecosystem, we
can actually publish that update
immediately and you can
come directly to us for that.
So that's the what
Ground Truth is.
That's the why we did it.
Now we're going to get to the
meat of the presentation which
is how it actually works, which
I keep hand waving.
So Ground Truth is basically
three pieces stacked on top of
each other.
The first, as I've kind of
already talked about, is
authoritative data.
We go directly to postal
services, we go directly to
governments, we go directly
to really well-known map
providers themselves,
and we get the data
directly from them.
We work out arrangements
where we can
absorb that data directly.
We combine that with internal
data that Google has.
This is one of the best
leverages that we have because
we're one of the few companies
that has all this satellite
and aerial imagery and all this
Street View imagery, and
you can conflate those two
together and correct
one with the other.
So even though you've got, say,
your roads from the city,
it turns out, when you look at
road data and you compare it
to satellite imagery,
it doesn't
always line up so great.
So you can correct the road
imagery and make it even more
accurate by snapping it
to what you see in
the satellite imagery.
Then the last chunk is
algorithms and elbow grease,
the byline of the talk.
This is actually where the meat
of everything happens,
and this is what we're
going to demo.
We apply a variety of stages of
work where we take the raw
data that we got from the
provider and we clean it up
successively.
For example, we actually take
the streets that they gave us
and we drag them manually to
match all of the roads that we
see in satellite imagery.
So there's a variety of manual
processes that go on as well
as a bunch of automated
algorithms like the computer
vision that I mentioned from
Street View, and we go through
successive stages of work where
we clean up different
aspects of the data, and out the
other end pops a map that
is higher quality than the
sum of its inputs.
So we're really going to focus
on this algorithms and elbow
grease part.
And to accomplish the algorithms
and elbow grease
part, we built a tool internally
called Atlas, and
this is a screenshot
from Atlas.
It's fully homegrown.
It's, unfortunately,
internal only.
You're going to get to see
some of it, but you
don't get to use it.
It's actually used by a team
of what we call operators,
Ground Truth operators, and this
is a dedicated internal
workforce that goes through a
huge amount of training on
policies, procedures, and the
tool itself so that they know
how best to implement the
policies that we've come up
with that result in a
high-quality map.
It's worth noting, we're going
to demonstrate a whole lot of
the elbow grease because
basically, algorithms are
really boring to demo.
It's no fun if we hit a button
and all of a sudden, there's a
name on a street.
So that's less visual.
It's more fun to work on
sometimes, but we're just
going to show some of
the manual stuff.
So with that, I'm going to hand
it over to Andrew and see
if the video setup here works.
ANDREW LOOKINGBILL: Hi.
So this is Atlas, the in-house
mapping tool we developed.
I'm biased, but it's actually
my favorite client for
consuming Street View
and satellite data.
In addition to what we've
published on maps.google.com,
where we have sub-meter
resolution imagery for 75% of
the population, we also have
access to assets that we don't
necessarily publish either for
age or aesthetic reasons.
This allows us to track changes
to an area over time.
We can also cleanly overlay
vector data, comparing one
against the other.
We also, in the tool, have
access to the five million
miles of driven Street
View data, 3,000
cities in 50 countries.
And again, even when immersed in
a panorama, you can cleanly
overlay vector data.
This is important for
maintaining spatial context.
Similar to the smooth
transitions into and out of
the Street View imagery, this
isn't just eye candy.
It increases productivity
because Ground Truth operators
don't need to pause to
reorient themselves.
Finally, you're looking at an
internal-only fisheye viewer
that we can use even in the
top-down mode to quickly
select a panorama of interest.
Now, sometimes when the source
data comes to us, it's in
pretty rough form.
This is actually TIGER road
data, the free, public domain
dataset we started
with in the US.
And if you look at it paired
over satellite imagery, you
can spot some problems.
Not only are there alignment
issues, but there are also
occasional connectivity
problems.
For this reason, the first
step that a Ground Truth
operator takes is to actually
bring the geometry into
alignment with satellite
imagery.
They can drag intersections to
deform entire sections of the
road network at once, and then
replace existing geometry with
new vertices.
One of the reasons we do this
instead of creating the road
network from scratch--
which, with our tools, might
be even faster--
is that in this way, we maintain
attributes of the
data such as names,
address ranges,
speed limits, et cetera.
Now, even geometry editing
actually requires a decent
amount of policy and a deep
understanding of how to model
road networks.
For example, here, we're
splitting a road into its left
and right halves, but doing
so creates a number of new
intersections that also
require careful
handling and policy.
Now, treating these details
consistently across a country
allows our products--
like driving directions,
et cetera-- to behave
consistently across a country
worth of data.
And this is one of the reasons
why operators require a good
deal of training before they're
fully proficient.
It's also critical for Project
Ground Truth that we get every
turn restriction for every
intersection correct.
An example of a turn
restriction, for instance, is
not being allowed to turn left
at a given stop light, or
perhaps not being allowed
to make a
U-turn on a given segment.
Now, here in the tool, you can
see if you enter along the
yellow arrow, you can exit along
any one of the green
arrows, but not along
the red arrow.
Editing this complex
data can be tricky.
In Atlas, we streamline the
process by providing a set of
keyboard shortcuts that allow
an operator to quickly hop
between all of the various
entrances and exits from an
intersection, perfecting
the turn restrictions.
They're often able to do this
based on the pavement markings
they see in aerial imagery, but
we also heavily rely on
integration with Street View.
In fact, they can even make
annotations, such as this one,
clipping a sign, to kind of
leave a trace of what they
were looking at when they
made a decision.
In fact, these clipped
annotations are even visible
in the top-down view, correctly
oriented to speed
the work of people
who come after.
Although in this situation,
we've chosen to focus on a
manual extraction of a piece of
information from the Street
View imagery, we actually have
computer vision algorithms
that do a fantastic job of
extracting a number of road
signs, as you'll see along the
southern part of this road.
So you have a number of people
editing very complex data
concurrently.
You start to worry about
data consistency.
What you need is a smart,
automated system that suggests
when possible errors might exist
in the data, sort of
like compiler warnings, that
might want warrant a human
second check.
In fact, in this case, we use
the same anonymized traffic
data on maps.google.com to
suggest that in fact, what we
have modeled in our data as a
two-way road might in fact be
a one-way road.
An operator claims the issue and
uses the available tools
and the Street View and
satellite imagery to determine
that yes, in fact, this road
should be one way.
They update the vector
data and move along.
But, if they had claimed this
issue and decided that it was
a false positive, they would
have resolved the issue in
such a way that that same issue
would never flag on that
same data again in the future.
Now sometimes, the data we
take in has strange,
consistent islands of error.
For instance, an entire
neighborhood worth of roads
might be offset by 1,000 feet,
or there might be consistent
errors with scale or rotation.
Correcting these one at a time
would be cumbersome.
Luckily, we have a few bulk
transform tools, such as the
one you see here.
An operator defines the area
over which they want the
transform to take effect and
then begins defining pairs of
control points.
Each pair of control points says
that this point on the
road network corresponds to
this point on the ground.
An operator can see a preview
of the transform vectors and
then continue to add pairs of
control points until they're
satisfied with the warp.
After they're satisfied that the
warp is going to do what
they expect, they can choose to
preview the warp and then
hit Save, which will actually
bulk transform all
of the data at once.
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK: So as you
saw, these are a couple of the
different kinds of stages of
work that we go through where
we clean up different
aspects of the data.
There's other stages where we
look at freeway signs and get
the freeway text, we look at
speed limits, we look at road
type, distinguish highways
from local roads.
So on the left is what
we started with.
Andrew mentioned TIGER.
This is actually a public domain
set for the US put out
by the Census Bureau.
The Census Bureau cares
about counting houses.
They don't care so much about
freeway off ramps, so it's
kind of a disaster
on the left.
After many, many stages of
clean up from us, on the
right, is what results for
the Ground Truth data.
One other example, a little
more zoomed in.
This is actually just around
the corner from Google's
Mountain View campus.
Again, on the left, there's
a freeway interchange and
everything's just
modeled wrong.
The connectivity is wrong.
The alignment is terrible.
We go in, we clean it up stage
after stage, and out the other
end pops polished data.
So that takes care of
what, why, how.
Now, we thought we'd talk
a little bit about
where we've done this.
So in a nutshell, Brian
McClendon, during the keynote
this morning, actually talked
about this a bit.
The green countries here are
where we've done Ground Truth.
We've done it in 43 countries
and regions.
They launched over the
past five years.
This is a ridiculous rate of
speed for mapping, actually.
We're quite proud of it.
And in these nine separate
launches that
are detailed below.
So it's been a long effort and
a lot of work, actually.
So the natural question that I
get whenever I show this is,
where are we going
to map next?
And this is probably the most
frequently asked question.
And unfortunately, the answer
is silence and crickets.
We don't like to speculate
about future
products and services.
What I can say, though, is that
this is an incredibly
efficient mapping machine
that we've built.
We're not about to
turn it off.
We do want to map more, and
these will not be the last of
the countries that
you hear of.
So in theory, that takes us
through what, why, how, and
where, but you get
a little bonus.
We're going to talk about beyond
Ground Truth and what
happens after we initially
publish the data.
The biggest challenge for any
mapmaker is that as soon as
you publish a map,
it's out of date.
By fixing it in any kind of
solid form, the world is
changing, the fixed
form is not.
So the world is updating,
the map has to update.
So the story doesn't end
with the mapping
for the first time.
You have to map for
the rest of time.
One of our main mechanisms
is something that we
call Report a Problem.
Users can click a link in the
lower right corner of the
map-- it also appears in a few
other spots in the UI--
and they're taken to a dialog
flow that lets them submit any
type of problem.
You can tell us that your house
is in the wrong place,
you can tell us that your city's
named wrong, you can
tell us that a street
has a wrong name.
And you submit that, and the
same operators, basically,
that do mapping, some of them
have been trained on how to
receive these reports.
And we receive several thousands
of these every day,
and we process them manually,
and get back to you.
Additionally, that's desktop.
You can also do this
on mobile.
On iOS, if you have the Google
Maps app, at any point in the
app, you just shake it and it
vibrates and pops up a little,
hey, do you want to send
some feedback?
One of those feedback flows
allows you to submit map data
corrections the same way
that desktop does.
On Android, you can press and
hold anywhere on the map and
basically bring up a Location
Pin, and then there's a Report
a Problem link from there.
Or in Driving Directions, the
little More menu has a Report
a Problem link.
So you can tell us that you
can't turn left here.
Or you can turn left here, why
isn't Google suggesting it?
Now the fun part, of course, is
that when you accept user
reports, you accept anything
and everything.
This is an actual report that
came in just after the
launch of the US.
"There's a field of
marijuana here.
Please call the cops." We really
do get anything and
everything.
This is somewhere in Michigan,
I guess, but
that's just how it goes.
If you want to go a step beyond
reporting a problem,
you can actually fix the
data directly yourself.
We offer a product called
Google Mapmaker,
mapmaker.google.com.
It lets you directly
edit the map data.
It's kind of like the tool Atlas
that Andrew has been
demonstrating, but
for the web.
It's a web-based map editor.
And when you submit edits on
Mapmaker, they go through a
moderation system.
So we, or a trusted external
user, actually validates the
edit that you suggest and
confirms whether it conforms
to all of our policies.
So we're going to demo
that a little bit.
ANDREW LOOKINGBILL: Excellent.
As Michael mentioned, we get
thousands of Report a Problem
reports every day, and the video
we're about to show--
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK:
Hopefully.
ANDREW LOOKINGBILL: --fingers
crossed, is actually a life
cycle for one of
those reports.
Actually, that's
the indoor one.
But--
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK:
One second.
ANDREW LOOKINGBILL: OK.
At any rate, what you're
actually going to see in the
video is a user who asks for
directions to a certain place,
gets the directions back, and
actually feels like telling us
that, in fact, the left turn
that they're directed to take
isn't possible in reality.
As a result, they try and
Report a Problem.
Now, using the interface that
Michael just showed you, it's
possible to select which
exact step you think
contains the problem.
The report's then sent to a
Ground Truth operator who uses
all of the tools and the imagery
that you've just seen
discussed to decide whether or
not the report has merit.
If they decide that yes, in
fact, the data needs to be
updated, they make the changes
and as soon as it's saved, all
of a sudden, other users
aren't given
data with that error.
So that's the Report
a Problem flow.
The Mapmaker one?
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK: Yeah,
we'll switch to Mapmaker.
Sorry.
ANDREW LOOKINGBILL: Excellent.
Also, Michael mentioned
Mapmaker.
Many of our users take all of
the stuff we've discussed and
want to take it a
step further.
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK:
Hang on one second.
Something is not going right.
OK, that one's queued up
for now, real quick.
ANDREW LOOKINGBILL: So this is
the Report a Problem flow I
just mentioned.
It's actually the left turn
that seems problematic.
You'll watch them Report
a Problem.
The nice thing is, you can
select the exact turn.
That in turn helps
the operator.
Feedback goes to one of our
Ground Truth operators.
They use the tool just as you've
been seeing so far.
They can look at the text as
well as what they see in the
area, the various state of the
intersection and the turn
restrictions we've been
discussing, all of the
overlaid vector data, and also
the imagery to decide that
yes, in fact, this left turn
shouldn't be allowed.
They restrict it and then
the edit goes live.
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK: And one
second for Mapmaker.
Sorry, we're doing a backup
presentation method.
ANDREW LOOKINGBILL: So as we
mentioned, a lot of users want
to take this one step further,
everything we've been talking
about today.
They want to actually edit the
map data directly, leveraging
their local expertise.
And for that, as Michael
mentioned, we have Mapmaker.
Here you actually see a video of
a user who's familiar with
a particular area.
They're taking a road and
they're starting to update
certain attributes of it,
including the name, the speed
limit, and whether or
not it's paved.
As the video goes on, you'll
actually see them use the
satellite imagery to perfect the
geometry of the segment so
that it exactly matches
reality.
Once they're done with their
edit, they'll submit it for
moderation, and once moderated,
the change will go
live within minutes on
maps.google.com.
It's a little long.
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK: So it's
very similar to Atlas editing,
but it's in a web editor so it's
very accessible to the
average user.
So we'll cut that off there.
Sorry about the technical
difficulties.
All right, and then the last
topic that we wanted to talk
about on that is indoor mapping,
what we call the
final frontier.
And there was actually just a
session on this, otherwise we
would be telling you
to go to it.
But basically, it's not
sufficient to map the outdoors.
We want to be able to give you
walking directions from your
terminal at the airport when
you land to your next gate,
and all sorts of things
like that.
So we're going to, hopefully,
have a demo video of that.
ANDREW LOOKINGBILL: So if you
attended Sarah and Waleed's
session on indoor mapping, you
know that we're starting to
bring the characteristic Google
Maps experience to the
interior of buildings as well.
So in theory, this is just an
extension of what we already
know how to do as far as map
data creation is concerned.
Take data, iterate on it, and
improve on it using our
existing tools.
In practice, however, there are
a couple of problems with
this, one of which being, we
can't actually do a good job
of tracing indoor maps from
satellite imagery because the
roofs of the buildings
get in the way.
You can see an exact
example of this.
This is Terminal 2 for SFO.
What's going on inside?
We have no idea.
Luckily, we have a few tricks
up our sleeve as well.
By partnering with building
owners, we can acquire digital
floor plan data.
We can align this in Atlas to
match with the building's
footprint so that Ground Truth
operators can begin the
process of mapping and modeling
things like security
checkpoints, elevators,
escalators, restrooms,
changing stations, et cetera.
Now, while in theory, this just
requires a little extra
toolwork to make sure that we
can visualize and edit things
on multiple floors, and also
cope with a feature density
that's up to three orders of
magnitude higher than for
outdoor mapping, the rest of
it's just business as usual.
In fact, you see here that we
even take pains to model the
indoor road network.
This corresponds to where you're
allowed to walk or not
walk inside the airport.
And as a result, if you're using
Google Maps for mobile,
we can direct you to your
connecting gate as soon as you
step off the flight.
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK: So let's
talk a little bit about what
this all amounts to in
terms of mapping at
the speed of Google.
We get thousands of these
Report a Problem
submissions a day.
Most of them are responded
to, actually,
within 24 to 48 hours.
We don't backlog them, so
we have to keep up.
Most of the edits that result
from these reports and from
Mapmaker go live within
minutes of approval.
I can't stress how
amazing this is.
We have multiple data centers
worldwide, multiple products,
we have a million
API websites.
All of them get updated, usually
within minutes, of
most edits being accepted.
So when we rename a road,
it happens pretty quick.
Additionally, all of that
happens within the context of
the rest of mapping at the speed
of Google in terms of
our products and services.
Our tiles that are served for
Google Maps-- these are the
images that load in in blocks
as the web page loads--
they have an average of 75
milliseconds for their serving
latency, which, if you are a
techie at all, is sort of
mind-blowing at the scale that
this is going on at.
We maintained four and a half
nines of uptime over the last
three years, which is
really, really high.
This actually means that if
Google Maps is down, chances
are it's your internet
provider, not us.
And at our peak, we
have served 1.6
million queries per second.
That's 1.6 million of those
little tiles going out every
second to users around
the world.
This stuff blows me away.
We also accept updates from
more than just our users.
We've talked a lot about our
user strategy here, but we go
back to our authoritative
sources.
We do have arrangements with
them where we refresh data.
We also, of course, are
re-driving Street View on a
regular basis, and in fact, some
of those re-drives happen
in response to user issues.
We do, in fact, go out and drive
places where we need to
clarify a mapping problem.
And then satellite imagery and
aerial imagery are constantly
being refreshed.
This is the other utterly
amazing thing to me.
Every two weeks, just every two
weeks, Google publishes as
much new imagery as all
of Google had in 2006.
That's how quickly we're
updating the aerial and
satellite imagery.
So we regularly drop issues
where we might not have a
clear enough view of the
intersection, and we go back,
then, when the imagery has
updated and fix the problem.
We also have this fun thing that
we call internally, the
Crystal Ball Report, and it's
basically a system that we
have for scanning social media
and news sites, and we try to
proactively identify issues
that users are complaining
about, but that they may not be
sending directly our way,
because it's also a source
of information.
So in some cases, we try to fix
things before they become
a story, and that's been
very effective.
So all of that amounts to
a map of the world.
And where is Google Maps
at this point?
We've talked a lot about Ground
Truth, we've talked a
little bit about Mapmaker.
But basically, this is the
present picture, and this was
presented in the keynote
this morning as well.
Google has, as of recently,
200 countries
mapped around the world.
We finally got North
Korea mapped.
The video rental model that I
spoke about in the beginning
is still in play in quite a
number of countries, and it is
actually an important
model for us.
In some cases, it's
what we prefer.
Ground Truth has launched in
43 countries and regions.
The most recent was Thailand
and Indonesia
just a few weeks ago.
And then the blue countries
are completely Mapmaker
sourced, and these are the
countries where users are the
ones that are generating the map
and we're just providing,
basically, a platform
for them to do so.
It's also worth mentioning that
many of the Ground Truth
countries have Mapmaker
launched as well.
So in the US, in the UK, in a
number of other countries, you
can directly edit the data.
And it's our intention that
wherever we do Ground Truth
mapping, we do want to support
Mapmaker as a venue for users
correcting the data.
So that's about all
we have for today.
Thank you all for coming,
and we'd be
happy to take any questions.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi my name
is [? Thibault. ?]
I work with a business software
and they usually have
warehouses and they don't want
to put their indoor maps on
the public internet.
Is there a possibility
to do indoor
marketing for private locations?
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK: So
there is a product.
Google Maps Engine will cover
some of that use case.
It's basically an online data
store but it's private.
It's [? ACL-ed ?]
with access restrictions so
that you can have private
instances of a map and you can
control who has access to it.
And I believe there's probably
sessions and probably some
demos as well.
AUDIENCE: Can you repeat
the name, please?
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK:
Google Maps Engine.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: One data source you
didn't mention is the hundreds
of millions of people walking
around using Google Maps on
their phones, and I would think
you'd be able to track
where they are and that you'd
know those were real roads and
real sidewalks.
Is that something you do,
or why not if you don't?
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK: So we do
leverage anonymized traffic
data for a lot of our
mapping processes.
Andrew demoed the one-way
detection that we did, and
that's one example of it, and
there's other places in the
data where we do try
to leverage that.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Could you go into a little bit
more detail about the computer
vision that you utilize?
I know you talked a little bit
about some sign detection and
stuff, but I wasn't quite clear
on whether you actually
look at the Street View or the
satellite imagery and infer
the roads from the
actual imagery?
And just a little bit more,
maybe, about the automation,
because I know you wanted to
talk more about the user
interface, but if you could
just go a little
bit more into that.
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK: Yeah, we
have a wide mix of manual
stuff and automated stuff.
The ones that we really like to
talk about are Street View
is the really big example.
We read numbers off of street
signs, we match templates and
spot street signs.
You can actually see-- a No Left
Turn in some countries is
always the same shape, and
so you can spot those
automatically.
There's also instances where we
can confirm street names.
I had one other and it
just slipped my mind.
But it's varied.
There's a wide variety
of them.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: I was just wondering
about how many people do you
have working on Google Maps
[? fitting ?] it themselves?
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK:
Work on, sorry?
AUDIENCE: How many people work
on the Google Maps themselves?
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK:
The operators?
AUDIENCE: How many operators
are there, yes?
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK: Yeah, so
we don't like to talk about
the exact size of
the workforce.
We do say, though, it takes
hundreds of people to map the
typical country, so it's a
very large-scale effort.
AUDIENCE: Hi, and please correct
me if this is going to
be addressed elsewhere in the
conference, but I have a
question about public transit
data, and in particular, are
you guys incorporating real-time
live transit data
into your directions?
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK: Yeah.
I'm not an expert on this, but
the two forms of transit data
that I'm aware of, we have a
data format that's public.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's GTLS.
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK: Yes.
And so people can publish the
basic static transit info.
And I do know that we serve
live transit info--
ETAs for trains, and where is
the current train, things like
that-- for a select
number of cities.
I don't know how many, and I'm
not sure of exactly how that
works, though.
AUDIENCE: G'day.
My company uses a lot of Google
Maps stuff, and I'm
just wondering, is there any
way that users can put in
colloquial names for places
or is there any--
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK:
Sorry, put in what?
AUDIENCE: Colloquial names
for places, so Joe's Pub.
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK: Does
Mapmaker support that?
ANDREW LOOKINGBILL: Mapmaker
does support that.
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK: Yeah.
So there's a whole schema and
set of classifications for how
you name things, whether it's a
city or a road, and we model
that in intricate detail and
flag something as its local
name, its obscure name that
maybe we shouldn't show but we
should show in response
to searches.
All that, we have modeling
internally for that, and much
of it is reflected on
Mapmaker so you can
directly edit that data.
AUDIENCE: What's the process
to upload that to you guys?
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK: We don't
have a method right now for a
mass upload.
It would be for individual
corrections.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was wondering, how do you
deal with updates to the
mapping data--
new projects, new roads,
or roads get blocked?
Is there a process that you
guys follow for that?
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK:
It's the things
that I outlined, basically.
We mostly rely on users.
Users are very proactive, and
actually wind up alerting to
us about most things.
The Crystal Ball Report is
really good, particularly for
large changes, even before
they happen.
We'll find out that a freeway
interchange construction is
going to finish, and we might be
able to open it on Maps the
same day that it opens
in the real world.
And then we do these re-drives
and re-flies of imagery, and
we revisit things
that we weren't
completely sure about before.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: One of my questions
was around the
date timing of things.
If an interchange is about
to open, or a bridge
construction, or something like
that, is it date stamped
where you can release a new
version of the map on a
particular day?
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK: So the way
that our systems work, we
don't actually model,
say, it's going
to open in two weeks.
There's no way in Mapmaker
to mark that.
But we have the ability for
big changes to kind of
synchronize and make sure
that we push it out
at the right time.
We're republishing
continuously.
It's actually not even as simple
as saying that we're
currently running a map that
was created a week ago,
because it's literally moment
by moment, there's users
interacting with it.
AUDIENCE: So that kind of
brings up my next one.
You've got incidents or events
with traffic data, right?
Is there any way to tie that
to longer-term events like
construction, road closures,
that kind of stuff?
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK: Tie it
to it as far as what?
AUDIENCE: Like if a lane is
going to be closed for two
weeks, or a month, or a year,
that kind of stuff?
Or bridge construction, or--?
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK: So we
have some guidelines
internally where if something's
going to go on for
more than a certain period of
time, we turn it into an
actual map data change.
If it's really transient in
nature, it shows up on the
traffic layer as like a little
warning sign or something, but
we don't modify the
data itself.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Just a question
on business data in less
developed countries, so things
like knowing the names of
businesses and their
GPS locations.
I used to live in Indonesia and
you were just saying you
just recently did Ground Truth
for there, but how do you do
the business part of it?
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK: So we
haven't talked a lot about
what we call local data, which
is business listings.
Map data is a piece of cake
compared to local data.
Particularly in some
countries like
Indonesia, it can be a challenge.
And there's no one answer.
We go into a country and we
source whatever we can, and in
some countries, that's
pretty high quality.
In other countries, it's
a little lower.
But we also rely
on users a lot.
India is pretty much exclusively
mapped by its
users, and it's a surprisingly
well-mapped country given that
starting point in many places.
So users are actually taking
ownership of whole
neighborhoods and curating
the businesses there.
So there's different strategies
for different places.
AUDIENCE: So sort of related
to that, you mentioned that
sometimes you prefer
user-submitted maps over
Project Ground Truth or some of
the other things that you
do, and I'm curious why that
would be the case.
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK: If I used
the word "prefer," that's
probably a strong word.
Ground Truth is very expensive
and difficult and
takes a lot of time.
It's going to take us a while
to map the countries that we
do want to map, and we just make
careful trade-offs and
try to figure out, what's the
best way to bring something to
market to users quickest?
And in the case of India, we
started Mapmaker there in
2008, 2009--
one of those two--
and so it got a huge jump start
long before we would
have been able to address
it with Ground Truth.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Eric, and I was wondering
if you guys were going to do
parking, because I see you guys
are able to pull business
logos, and you guys obviously
have a lot of city data as
well, and obviously when we
drive anywhere, that's a big
part of what our actual
destination is?
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK: Yeah, I
mean, parking information is
something of interest to us.
Ultimately, we basically want
to model the entirety of the
real world on the map.
It should be possible for you
to answer any question that
has a place using the map.
AUDIENCE: So following up on
India, you mentioned that you
rely entirely, or almost
entirely, on user-submitted
mapping, and other countries
as well.
So it's my understanding
that this is
entirely a closed system.
So do you ever give back?
It's kind of like users
are sort of doing your
business for you.
Do you ever give back to
them, or are they just
contributing for free?
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK: Yeah.
So we do, in a number of
countries, actually give back.
I don't remember if India's
one of them or not, but
there's a list of countries that
have humanitarian needs
that we make the data
available to
NGOs free of charge.
It is the case that you can't
directly download the data.
We've taken the approach that
we believe that this type of
ecosystem is going to be
the most effective.
If they download it and they try
to fork it or they try to
modify it, it's unclear what
you'd want to do with it.
Additionally, we really feel
that the Maps API is sort of
the optimal way to leverage the
geodata, so we do want to
enhance the API over time to do
anything that you'd want to
do by downloading the data.
AUDIENCE: So my question is
related to Ground Truth data
for indoor maps.
So if I get it correctly right
now, they're focusing on users
to give indoor maps
information.
So what's your thought about--
you have self-driven cars for
outdoor environments--
something like that, close to a
robot, to go around, collect
the data for you, for Ground
Truth information?
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK: So you're
asking if we are going to make
robots to roam the airports
and map the interior?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, or self-driven
cars indoors
which would help you?
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK: I think
that's a great idea, and you
should go track down Larry or
Sergei and apply for a job at
Google X. It's a hard problem,
and it's also a scaling
problem and questions
of logistics.
So is it easier to
put humans there?
Is it easier to put
robots there?
And who would be better at it?
AUDIENCE: I guess like the
sensors they've been using
right now are just Wi-Fi, so if
you had sensor information
from cameras and stuff, visual
information, it would be
easier to map those locations.
Or do you have any sensor inputs
from the users that
they could give for visual
information?
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK:
That's conceivable.
It's an interesting idea, and
it's not far off from--
Brian, in the keynote, he showed
that interior 3D photo
tour, and there's a lot of
information being constructed
there about the interior
of a famous place.
So it's an interesting idea.
ANDREW LOOKINGBILL: And this
does give us a chance to pitch
a talk that's occurring tomorrow
on localization.
We're incredibly agnostic about
what we use as far as
sensors and technologies,
so we'll try anything.
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK: Do you know
the title of the talk?
ANDREW LOOKINGBILL: No, but it
might have localization in it.
If you can find me afterward,
I'll make--
AUDIENCE: Internationalization
and localization,
something like that?
ANDREW LOOKINGBILL:
It's not that one.
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK:
It's localization
in a spatial sense.
ANDREW LOOKINGBILL: If you can
find us afterward, we'll give
you the information.
AUDIENCE: Thanks a lot.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
As some of you guys might know,
there's another project
that's doing a lot of this,
Open Street Map.
And I'm wondering if you could
talk a little bit about your
relationship with them, and
has that changed at all?
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK: Yeah.
I, and virtually everybody in
Google Maps, are huge fans of
Open Street Map.
I think it's a really
cool project.
To date, we haven't worked
very closely with them.
We've supported them
in the past with
some funds or something.
They have a very different
approach.
They're doing a very
open approach.
We are, as was commented, it's
a more closed ecosystem.
But competition is awesome, and
it's not a zero sum game,
as Larry was saying, and it's
not a win all or take all
because in some places, one
model might work better.
In some places, others will.
So we'll just have to see.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
ANDREW LOOKINGBILL:
With 30 seconds
left, maybe last question.
AUDIENCE: How do you to report
a problem which is not
specific to a location, but
probably a wrong algorithm?
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK: Probably
wrong what?
AUDIENCE: A wrong algorithm.
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK: Can
you give an example?
AUDIENCE: In my city, if you
look for a street and you
don't specify the first name of
the person of the street,
you don't find the result.
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK: You
should come talk to us.
ANDREW LOOKINGBILL: Come find us
after, but a larger answer
to that is, we accept
incredibly
general input on RMI--
AUDIENCE: And I think it
happened when Ground Truth was
introduced last year.
ANDREW LOOKINGBILL:
Come find us.
MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK:
It's hard to get
everything exactly right.
But as Andrew was saying, if you
report a problem, even if
it's general, it does
flow into a
larger bucketing system.
And we address all scale
of complaints.
I think we're out of time.
Thanks everybody again
for coming.
[APPLAUSE]